and if if if it's not a glowing review
you know uh these certain individuals
will call and king are you implying that
because any negative so many uh comments
are made that
that something may happen that there are
repercussions for them
i mean
they didn't get a review unit i should
feel like they should speak for itself
so i can say we're not going to get one
the future
okay
they didn't get a review a review a unit
um and the unit that they did get was
like date and date and we got to give
the impressions right then and there
yeah i just feel that if somebody's
going to talk the truth about something
they don't get a review of the unit
because they are fearful that the truth
i don't know
i personally feel like when it comes to
the whole argument people was like oh if
they got review codes review units that
like look like
in that case don't watch anything ever
don't look at anything
don't read any reviews don't read any
product reviews because all of these
people got review units for them
for but you know in in in contrast
you had uh
two
uh xbox series x's you had a beta unit
and then you had the retail unit that
was okay listen you can review this and
then we're going to ship out this one
that is actually what everybody else is
going to get and hey
say with it as your wilt and
i just feel like that's it that's a
better practice um i don't yeah that was
way better so i know even the people who
got the the review units for the ps5 got
him like
really late like
i think like a week i want to say i
don't know if it was on purpose i'm
gonna be real with you so like yeah so
just actually xbox did it great so jimmy
like if if you got a movie to to talk
about
and they gave it to you the day before
the movie came out
it kind of would like make you go hmm
right like
that can work negative too though
because the first impression there's a
lot of movies where i see it in my first
impression i come out here like
yeah i don't know about that you know
what sits with you like malignant would
definitely be one of those movies where
a week later like you know like first
gut check on that one i'm like
that was nuts like
that was not what i was expecting and
then
you start to like it more as you think
about it right so with movies it's a
little different but i think yeah i
don't know like having the xbox that
long was sweet because
we could play xbox games we could play
xbox one games we can play 360 games we
can test everything on it and to be fair
sony there's not much you could really
test on that console with the ps4 games
like
the the biggest thing that just like is
crazy is just like look like
people can't speak their opinion about
anything because it's like the moment
you speak your opinion you're put in two
camps yeah you can't like
you know i don't say that
and it's just it's crazy how the
industry works and you know i personally
feel like i don't know about you jimmy
but i personally feel like you know
there are scenarios where companies will
put out you know maybe not necessarily
consoles but i i think it happens a lot
in games really like let's let's give
them the review code the day before it
comes out so they're going to rush the
review and not really let it sink in
like
i didn't yeah i don't know firsthand but
dude i could totally see that happening
like
yeah i don't know with the ps5 i feel
like that console is coming in hot
anyway right like
no pun intended oh my god
jimmy i was there look at the can of
words
i'm trying to save you for this
i thought you guys wanted to talk about
it so i'm going to keep i'll let you
keep talking about it no no no listen
listen he's he's talking his truth we
got to let jimmy talk baby
everything that i don't like about the
ps5 i was able to pick up on like
immediately
but that wasn't my video it was austin's
video it's his first impressions xbox
still his first impressions his video so
i can't talk to what he's saying but if
you ask me which console i would have
gone with
like day one
because i mainly play on pc i would have
gone with the ps5 but if you ask me like
which one was most buttoned up at launch
i don't think you could really make an
argument against the xbox or zx like
that was
just it was i saw it so early too
running games great that yeah they just
knew what they were doing with it which
you know not to say that somebody does
it but i've had every sony console i've
had i'll be honest with you guys i have
a playstation channel so take it with a
great assault whatever
every sony console i've had ever has had
some critical hardware failure within
four years my ps3 blu-ray laser broke my
ps4 launch unit the fan went out which
was super annoying like trying to get
that fixed especially since you guys
know i have to work hard when i was
younger to get all this stuff absolutely
after and then my ps4 pro the blu-ray
laser broke within a year and a half
which is nuts and then i'm finding out
they're doing the same thing they're
doing with this ps5 they have so many
different ps4 pros it's insane how many
revisions the ps4 pro they were and i
just got luck unlucky i guess where one
breaks my vita battery went out there's
always something with these consoles
right
my xbox the 360 i got the red ring but
you got to look at the one i got it was
a used unit from gamestop selection what
refurbishments are they doing on that
right it was a launch one and every xbox
360 got the red rings it was just a
critical hardware problem ever since
then never had a problem with the xbox
console and i've had an xbox jimmy ones
what i'm
[Laughter]
treating you right
so you know the playstation's been
breaking down and you know uh jimmy i
want you to gain in in a better space
[Laughter]
i only have my players on pc anyway yeah
i don't i only had one uh playstation
messed up on me and really to fix it to
be honest with you i always thought that
hardware was done really well i can't i
can't rely on that um my it was my
playstation 3
and i saw this like yellow light and i'm
like what the hell is this
what's going on but then they told me it
was the laser and you know they fixed it
really quickly i got it back really fast
um but i've never and i'm i can't i
can't lie on them you know i always
thought they their heart was pretty
decent but
you said that i was like
and it's different for me because you
know i didn't have a lot of money so i
was like no like i don't like i'm not
going to be able to just go fix it if i
can't yeah
it does out of warranty when it happens
it's like man well guess guess uh i
guess i don't have a console right now
and that sucks
again
salute to you guys you know in reference
to at least pointing out one thing i
think that i think it's lost in all this
and to solve credit which i am glad he
brought up because i was definitely not
going to bring this up saul forced this
issue and salute to him for making a
great segment cassava does make great
subjects what he does but um i think
what it is is you guys don't get enough
credit for pointing out the fact that
there even was a revision because let's
be honest without your guys reporting
regardless of whatever's cooling
situation we wouldn't have known the
image change so i think yeah yeah that's
lost to this salute to you guys for
doing the research i did want to ask um
real quick i'd always stay along on this
but when they when you guys with the
series x were you part of that with
austin part of that team when they got
it early like with jason ronald and
everyone in the room or was
how did that work i was just curious
about that so there's a video on
austin's channel called building the
ultimate xbox or something like that
it's like it's it's got a cool thumbnail
like all the xboxes it's yellow
i wrote that video and i i went up to
microsoft and i interviewed a ton of
people there like so all the interview
footage you see in that video is me so i
wrote this i wrote like a book like i
could take the script for that video and
turn it into a book
and then
that was used like as like an example of
like why we do good work right so that's
how we got to go with digital foundry
and do the um here's that thing so i was
there nice that's that one i didn't do
much on i was just kind of there you
know like so using a ruler
next gen like i played sata decay 2 and
i did oh my god
yeah the hot switching
games
so that was that was just fun you know i
was getting paid to just hang out there
and then
by the time
every all the consoles came into work i
was mainly working on the second channel
this is okay and i was doing a lot of
editing there and that those are longer
videos triple cams the editing would
take up a lot of time so i was like in
the office but that was just largely
like austin just kind of doing his own
thing because when i was working with
austin
i was just like editor you know i was
editing most of the videos i was in i
was in the office but when when you're
editing
like 8k footage and all this stuff it's
it's a lot of work you know so it's not
like it's a fun job right it's a cool
job it's not like a regular job but it's
work so i wasn't around for all the like
most of the fun stuff there but um
yeah i mean i don't know i'm not i don't
care like i'm
i think that's like why
people like sacred symbols why people
have like taken a little bit of a shine
to my channel it's because
like i i don't like if you criticize
sony they just get better and they
respond they respond pretty well like
criticism they don't respond with words
they respond just like with silent
changes but
you could track like a lot of their
biggest controversies having direct
results on their future consoles which i
like i think that's cool like
prove it you know like don't just give
me words and say you're gonna fix it
blah blah just do it and don't make a
big deal
there's a demographic of people
that feel like
doing stuff like that is a sign of
weakness yeah and they they need to to
stick to their guns and i'm like no
you want to see me get defensive we'll
talk about
like
i'm like i could never do a channel
about like pc gaming or steam because
i'd get so defensive i would say stupid
[ __ ]
dang it
stupid crap i'd be like get you know but
yeah the consoles are fun because it's
like you can look at them from the
outside and be like oh which is better
but i think xbox
has improved a lot you know so let's see
man i know yeah well they have to
improve if they're losing so yeah
i mean that's how we got the ps4 that's
how we got all the best exclusives on
the ps3 that's how yes like that's the
ps3 not doing well is why sony is where
they are
remember
i do
beginning of ps4 generation sony is like
peak sony in my lifetime yeah focusing
on indies focusing on awesome like niche
exclusives like bloodborne we'll never
get a game like bloodborne again i know
people are holding out hope
everything they're telling you they're
telling you right now they're saying no
big budget a big seller
that is not bloodborne like bloodborne
is a
small dedicated audience like big for a
souls game small compared to sony's
other stuff so yes
yeah like when sony loses we win it's
like alien versus predator
absolutely man again love the
transparency love what you're doing to
this space you know again the unique
combination with the producing the
youtube the horror the filmmaking
tremendous history